we could start a new country which
religion would be the best religion to
start the country on which religion
would be the best religion to start a
new country
um
this is a really really good question
because on the one hand no religion has
a monopoly on Democracy the idea that
democracy fits better with like
Christianity than it does with Islam is
demonstrably false
um
but
the the one big advantage of
Christianity
is that it has fully and completely
married itself to capitalism
and so if you were going to start a
country that re that required economic
success
capitalism is the right way to do it so
I would say yeah probably some kind of
protestant some kind of protestant
version of Christianity would be a great
start but I will say one thing
democracy true liberal democracy isn't
dependent on secularism secularism does
not a democracy make
pluralism is what makes democracy the
whole point of a democracy is that
individuals get to vote on things based
on their own personal ideas and beliefs
and whether you like it or not for the
vast majority of humans on Earth their
personal beliefs and identities are
enrapped around religious identity so to
say that religion should not have a role
to play in democracy means that there's
no democracy that's what that means
the question is can you have the proper
safeguards in place to make sure that
people who do not adhere to that
majority religion or or to religion at
all are equally protected from having
their rights infringed upon by the
religion of the majority that's what the
United States was supposed to be with
the the you know anti-establishment
Clause uh but you know we are 350
million people
of which
150 million of us are right-wing
Evangelical Christians who believe that
the country is a Christian Nation and
should be based on Christian principles
and laws and that non-christians would
have a a a a sort of
secondary role you know as second-class
Citizens in that kind of country well
that's legit that's like half the
country that's a serious threat so all
religion can threaten Democratic
institutions but if I were to start all
over again and it had to be founded on a
religious tradition I think I'd probably
pick Protestants so in other words
you're a capitalist Protestant who
chooses to argue socialist Muslim what a
strange life that's about that's about
right so listen at the way the way I
want everything to be is a Protestant
capitalist because it makes me wrapped
in a country but do you know first of
all I appreciate you for being honest
because you know you could have taken
that and manipulated it and taken many
different angles to kind of make the
argument better for you but you took the
argument and just straight up said what
you would what would make you feel safer
why didn't you say Muslim why Why not
start a country and it being based on
Islam Muslim being the original
foundations of the country again so
Islams right there are multiple multiple
and a socialist why not create a country
based on you know like the
judeo-christian no we're going to be
Muslim we're going to follow Prophet
Muhammad we're going to fight we're
gonna have a socialist Nation why don't
you start a nation based on I would also
excise the phrase judeo-christian from
your language right away that's a
[ __ ] phrase invented by white
Protestants in order to in order to to
to bring Jews into the fold no Jew uses
the term judeo-christian
um and and the the the the contradiction
between those terms is hilarious the the
whole point of Christianity is that
there's no more need for Judaism because
one Jew said so
um so it's just judeo-christian is just
this bizarre fake term to basically mean
white that's what it means it means
White
um stop using it
um uh you just triggered my friend over
here wait what was the question I'm
sorry so so yeah you know how I got true
you know how America is built on a
judeo-christian okay why not start your
country where America is built on
protestantism let's be very Quran
Prophet Muhammad
tell me
no when you go when you go back and take
a look
um basically the founding father is
radius more than anything else deism is
a form of protestantism
um deism is protestantism that's what it
is I I think if you want it to be it can
be if it helps your argument it can be
but I when you hear people saying well
you know go take a look at the things
that are at the Lincoln Memorial and the
Jefferson Memorial and I've heard that
over and over and over again in various
speakers
um were Christian pastors there are no
scriptures carved in those things there
there are none and as a matter of fact
it was Thomas Jefferson who built and as
a scholar you probably know this you
know the Virginia the Virginia religious
Clause where he listed everybody and he
used the word infidels because he
thought that all people should be
protected in America to have the freedom
freedom of expression but this was a
these were deists that applied certain
things you look at Jefferson goes back
to France before he gets his writings
Hamilton came from Perkins Saint Croix
right but all of these come together the
deism that may have been influenced by
Christianity but first and foremost they
they were deist not Protestant pastors
but no they're not pastors they're not
religious Scholars nor were they nor are
they Protestant Scholars but
they weren't Protestant skull they
weren't Scholars at all but what this
argument that you hear all the time that
you know the founding fathers were
deists is a absolutely correct and deism
is a movement that arises out of
protestantism the primary purpose of
protestantism is to say that we don't
need an institution to interpret the
scripture for us we can interpret it on
our own that means we value the
scripture we don't we don't think the
scripture is is false or unnecessary
it's just that I don't need an
intermediary between me and the
scripture to tell you what it means
hence Thomas Jefferson pulled out his
scissors and said I don't like this
verse and you just cut it out I don't
like this section and he cut it out
deism isn't some brand new religion
invented by the founding fathers it is a
natural progression from protestantism
and it's thousands of thousands of sects
from Quakers to Shakers to methodists to
Baptists deists were just one of the
many many many
uh uh interpretations that arose we can
move on and disagree because deism has
such roots and basically all men seek
that when you find Native Americans that
they encountered when they Iroquois when
they first came here they said isn't it
interesting that the Iroquois seemed to
seek this Creator this God and sometimes
it's wrath the sun god of the Egyptians
sometimes it's other things deism I
thought had a true ten all men seek not
image and recognizing men meaning all
civilizations all living humans
ultimately are seeking isn't it
interesting when we encounter them that
they have their way of seeking this this
thing this Creator whatever they want to
call to move on to them we can move on
to them so going back to it so if if
America is a judo Christian Nation okay
I'm gonna keep saying that
so for you why not start a country based
on the Quran following Prophet Muhammad
and socialism
well I think the uh the like I said it
was the the issue of capitalism that I
think is the big is the biggest
capitalist and we're all capitalists man
look at you you're a capitalist we're
all I'm a proud capitalist I don't know
if you're a proud capitalist I will I
will go I'm uh I'm a moral capitalist I
do not believe in the Invisible Hand of
the free market if that's what you're
asking so you're I don't I don't worship
the Invisible Hand I don't know the
difference between a capitalist and a
moral capitalist you're talking
criminals that's what you're talking
about I mean I'm with you it's like
saying I believe when when people say I
I don't believe in uh uh uh pedophilia
within the churches and what you think I
believe in them I guess so so of course
I support moral capitalism no but so
you're a capitalism I bet I bet that you
have a almost religious-like faith in
the power of the free market to set its
own uh agendas and regulations and
limitations and that if you just leave
it alone it will take care of it'll take
care I used to until I study China okay
I used until I studied China because
when I started China and I realized in
the 80s they only had four law schools
and it was a doggy dog type of an
environment you start realizing you need
Law and Order and some regulation it's
the over regulation I have a challenge
with where the bigger companies use
lobbyists and politicians that are broke
to buy them to create laws to make it
tougher for the smaller guy to compete
with them that's the problem I was just
growing yeah that's what I would say um
so you're a capitalist so that's good
though I will say the one thing that
I've always read about Twitter is going
to Trend today saying Reza Hassan said
he's a hardcore capitalist exactly I'm
no longer on Twitter so I couldn't give
a [ __ ]
um uh the uh why are you no longer on
Twitter I I uh deactivated all of my
social media accounts as well as part of
my oh it's by your choice so you're not
on you're not in the penalty box or
something no no I um it was part of my
uh my kind of my New Year's uh
resolution to my wife although I did
four days ago no I actually I did it
early I did it in November right I I
went a little bit early as soon as as
soon as musk was like I'm letting Trump
back on I was like all right that's
enough for me so I was that the trigger
point I mean I was gonna do it January
1st uh as part of my New Year's
resolution but I was like [ __ ] it I'll
do it November 19th do you believe that
I know we're going off topic here but
I'm not going to get the questions
answered I swear to God I got 30 minutes
left you guys keep taking things
different directions but you constantly
here this is the third time I'm trying
to get a questions answered yeah well he
brought it up so no ultimated this
Twitter then you went with a question
about Twitter I hear no more questions
the
Ayatollah of Iran should be on Twitter
but Donald Trump should not
I I don't think the Ayatollah Iran
should be on Twitter
no but he is
yeah Trump was off
well again Trump is an insurrectionist
who tried to destroy American democracy
and uses his Twitter to to uh actively
promote violence actively promote
violence against his enemies there's no
room in on Twitter for someone like that
doesn't the Ayatollah do the same thing
but much worse well the Ayatollah is on
Twitter in charge of a fascist a
religious fascist regime that murders
children and uses his Twitter account uh
in order to promote propaganda and lies
about what he's doing he doesn't belong
on Twitter yeah why would he still be on
them what actually the [ __ ] up I don't
know guys I think it's very important to
realize like where he's at he's saying
neither should be on his position it's
better to ask her why do you not believe
both should be on then why how many how
many go back to your question so I'm
going to stay on this question guys go
go ahead because I got 30 minutes before
I get on my Max 7 call so okay so why
not start a country based on socialism
Muslim book of Quran I will say the one
thing the one thing that I that I do I'm
fascinated by Islamic Finance right this
idea uh and Jewish Finance is the same
way that the the prohibition against
interest and usury that there are ways
to do that that are that and and there
have been a number of very successful
ways of doing this where
um the way that it works is that instead
of loaning someone money to start a
business you invest in that business and
so there isn't any interest that you're
owed but you are owed dividends from the
uh from the business that's how most
Islamic financing things work and the
idea there being that hey we're all in
this together it's not like I loaned you
a hundred thousand dollars your business
collapsed too bad where's my money
um
but like most things it has been
absolutely infected by Western
capitalism so that you can say we're not
charging interest and so therefore
staying islamically compliant but this
investment comes with fees
that are essentially interest and that
make it very very difficult for these
small businesses to actually function if
you want to start I mean I would took
your question very very literally like
I'm starting a country from scratch
right which requires an enormous amount
of economic stability and build up how
would I do that well I would need
capitalism and
Islam is not exactly conducive to
capitalism neither is Judaism
but protestantism
it's it's not just conducive to
capitalism it is capitalism radical
individualism you have been in in not
all protestantism uh but like in
calvinist Evangelical you know
Presbyterian uh uh protestantism you've
already been predestined you've been
prejudged to be successful if you have
money it's because God likes you that's
why if you don't have money it's well
you should really look at yourself and
figure out why
um those are you know immoral ways of
thinking about money but if I'm starting
a country from scratch right and I want
this thing to last yeah I'd probably
start with a good dose of protestantism
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]